>> LITTLE PENCIL NECK ADAM
SCHIFF.
I SAW HIM TODAY.
"WELL, WE DON'T REALLY KNOW.
THERE STILL COULD HAVE BEEN SOME
RUSSIA COLLUSION."
SICK, SICK!
THESE ARE SICK PEOPLE.
>> Laura: PRESIDENT TRUMP
TAKING ON HOUSE INTEL CHAIR ADAM
SCHIFF OVER HIS PATHETIC
ALARMISM, CLAIMING COLLUSION
WITH NO EVIDENCE.
SHIFT CLASHED TODAY WITH MEMBERS
OF HIS OWN COMMITTEE AT A
HEARING AND MIKE NEXT GUEST IS
AMONG THOSE DEMANDING THAT
SCHIFF
RESIGN.
>> I WILL NOT YIELD.
>> WILL YOU YIELD --
>> YOU ATTACKED ME IN YOUR
OPENING STATEMENT --
>> I HAVE NOT HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
TO RESPOND ESPECIALLY TO YOUR
STATEMENTS.
>> I'VE EXPOSED HE WAS HAVING
ABUSE YOUR POSITIONS AND ONLY
FROM UP FALSE RESIGNATION DOWN
THE INFORMATION.
>> I'M ASKING FOR YOUR
RESIGNATION BECAUSE I THINK
YOU'RE ADVANCING CUTIN
PUTIN'S WORK.
>> YOU ARE ACCUSING THE
PRESIDENT OF TREASON.
>> Laura: ALMOST FELT LIKE THE
HOUSE OF COMMONS, IT GOT SO
RAUCOUS.
LOVE IT, THE BREAKFAST STUFF
BREXIT STUFF.
CONGRESSMAN, LET'S START WITH
YOU.
SCHIFF IS NOT GOING TO STEP
DOWN.
THAT'S PIE IN THE SKY THINKING.
SO WHAT IS THE RECORD IS HERE?
HOW CAN THE COMMITTEE, WHICH IS
CRITICAL TO OVERSIGHT, HOW CAN
THIS COMMITTEE BE LED BY SOMEONE
WHO HAS LIED OVER AND OVER AGAIN
USING THE WEAPON OF TREASON?
AND TRUMPING A RUSSIAN AGENT?
>> LAURA, YOU ARE RIGHT.
HE'S NEVER GOING TO STEP DOWN
FOR IT WE NEVER REALISTICALLY
ANTICIPATED HE WOULD.
WE STILL HAD RESPONSIBLE HE DID
TELL HIM AND TELL THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THE TRUTH.
WE ARE DISAPPOINTED WE REACH
THIS.
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASON WHY WE
ARE ON THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE, VERY IMPORTANT WORK
WE NEED TO DO, BUT WE REACHED A
POINT THAT HE WAS SO BLINDED BY
POLITICS WHERE HE'S RULED BY
EMOTION AND NOT FACT AND WE
NEEDED TO MAKE THAT CLAIM.
LAURA, LET ME TELL YOU WHAT THE
BIGGEST LIE THAT HE AND OTHERS
HAVE TOLD, THE CLIP SAID HE HAS
ACCUSE THE PRESIDENT OF TREASON,
ACCUSED OF ALIGNING HIMSELF WITH
A FOREIGN GOVERNMENT, NOT ONLY
ANOTHER FOREIGN GOVERNMENT, OUR
ADVERSARY FOR GENERATIONS.
THIS IS A VERY SERIOUS CHARGE
AND IF THEY REALLY BELIEVED IT,
THEY WOULD REQUIRE -- THEY WOULD
WORK TOWARDS HIS IMPEACHMENT.
I THINK THE BIGGEST LIE IS THEY
DON'T BELIEVE IT'S TRUE.
THEY KNOW IT'S NOT TRUE BUT THEY
DO NOT WANT TO DO --
>> Laura: THEY DON'T CARE.
THEY DON'T CARE.
CONGRESSMAN, THEY DON'T CARE
WHAT'S GOOD FOR THE COUNTRY.
THIS IS ABOUT UNDOING THE
RESULTS OF THE ELECTION AND IF
AMERICA HAD TO GET DRAGGED INTO
THIS TWO AND A HAPPIER
NIGHTMARE, DIDN'T MATTER.
JOHN SOLOMON, I'VE GOT TO TELL
YOU, NANCY PELOSI OUT THERE, SHE
WAS THROWING OUT THE BALLAST FOR
SCHIFF.
>> THEY ARE JUST PLAIN AFRAID.
THEY ARE AFRAID OF THE TRUTH,
THEY ARE AFRAID OF CONFIDENCE.
I'M SO PROUD OF THE WORK OF THE
CHAIRMAN ADAM SCHIFF.
WHAT IS THE PRESIDENT AFRAID OF?
I THINK THEY ARE JUST SCAREDY
CATS.
>> Laura: SOME HIGH-MINDED
RHETORIC THERE.
SCAREDY CATS?
I'M RUBBER, YOU'RE GLUE.
>> THIS IS SPRING TRAINING.
IT'S GOING TO GET A LOT HOTTER
BEFORE IT'S ALL DONE TO IT WHEN
THE PRESIDENT DECLASSIFIED ALL
THESE DOCUMENTS AND SEE IN REAL
TIME WHAT ADAM SCHIFF IS BEING
TOLD BEHIND CLOSED DOORS, WE CAN
COMPARE WITH WHAT HE SET OUT
FROM
SAID
OUT FRONT, WE KNOW MULTIPLE
BRIEFINGS OCCURRED THAT SAID NO
COLLUSION, AND HE'S OUT DRIVING
THOSE NARRATIVES.
WHEN THESE TWO DOCUMENTS CAN BE
COMPARED, THEN THERE DOWN
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC WILL BE MORE
CONCERNED THAN THEY ARE TODAY?
>> Laura: WHAT KIND OF GUY IS
HERE?
I'VE ONLY SEEN HIM TRASHING
TRUMP ON TV.
I'VE NEVER MET HIM.
WHAT KIND OF A PERSON HE IS
QUITE SMACKS TO COLLECT MOST OF
MY COLLEAGUES, YOU DON'T GET
ELECTED UNLESS YOU ARE
INTELLIGENT, ARTICULATE, I THINK
IN SOME CASES EMBRACING.
ALL OF THOSE ARE -- HE'S NO
FOOL, I'LL TELL YOU THAT.
WHICH BRINGS ME TO THE FACT THAT
HE'S NOT BEING FOOLED BY THIS.
HE HASN'T BEEN DECEIVED.
HE KNOWS THE TRUTH, JUST LIKE
YOU AND I KNOW THE TRUTH.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW THE
TRUTH.
HE JUST MADE A CALCULATED
POLITICAL DECISION THAT HE
DOESN'T CARE WHAT IS TRUE.
HE JUST HATES THE PRESIDENT SO
VISCERALLY AND IS SO OFFENDED
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WOULD CHOOSE
THIS PRESIDENT OVER HIS FRIEND
HILLARY CLINTON, HE'S
ESSENTIALLY SAID THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE STUPID, WE ARE GOING
TO OVERTURN THAT DECISION, AND
WE ARE GOING TO DO IT BY
DESTROYING THIS PRESIDENT
THROUGH LIES AND ACCUSATIONS
THAT HE KNOWS ISN'T TRUE.
>> Laura: LOOK, DEFAMATION
LAWS DON'T APPLY HERE, BUT I
HAVE TO TAKE ISSUE WITH HOW
SMART SCHIFF IS.
FORMER PROSECUTOR -- HE WENT TO
LAW SCHOOL.
I KNOW A LOT OF LAWYERS WHO
AREN'T SMART.
I'M A LAWYER.
REMEMBER WHAT HAPPENED NOT SO
LONG AGO WHEN A PRANKSTER CALLED
HIM?
>> MET WITH TRUMP, ALSO KNOWN AS
A PERSON WITH A STRANGE
REPUTATION.
>> HOW DO YOU SPELL HER NAME?
>> OLGA BUSERNOV.
>> WHAT WAS THE NATURE OF THE
COMPROMISE?
>> THERE WERE PICTURES OF NAKED
TRUMP.
>> Laura: I'M SORRY!
I MEAN...
THIS IS ONE OF THE FUNNIER
MOMENTS IN A VERY SAD SAGA.
>> IT IS A SAD SAGA AND THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE SMART
ENOUGH, 70% OF PEOPLE SAID IN A
POLL SAID THEY TRUST MUELLER,
THEY WILL NOT TRUST B24 ON
ON SCHIFF ON THIS.
I THINK THEY ARE TRYING TO KEEP
PEOPLE AWAY FROM WHAT HAPPENED
IN THIS, THE DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL
COMMITTEE WAS WORKING WITH A
FOREIGN POWER, UKRAINE, TO GET
SOME OF THEIR DIRT ON
DONALD TRUMP.
THAT'S NOT WHAT THEY WANT TO DIG
INTO.
>> Laura: YOU'VE BEEN DIGGING
IN IT.
I'VE BEEN READING YOUR REPORTING
ON THAT.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE NEXT
REPORT.
OUR COLLEAGUE ANDY NAPOLITANO
SAID THIS ABOUT -- WELL, SCHIFF
IS KIND OF RIGHT ABOUT
MENTIONING SOME OF THIS
CONSPIRACY STUFF.
LET'S WATCH.
>> CONGRESSMAN SCHIFF IS
CORRECT.
IN THAT REPORT WILL BE EVIDENCE
OF THE EXISTENCE OF A
CONSPIRACY.
NOT ENOUGH TO PROVE THE
EXISTENCE BEYOND A REASONABLE
DOUBT.
IF HE HAS OTHER SOURCES, HE HAS
TO DECIDE WHEN AND UNDER WHAT
CIRCUMSTANCES TO REVEAL THOSE
SOURCES.
>> Laura: WHEN I DO NOT KNOW
WHY ANDY IS THROWING A LIFELINE
TO SPEED
24 HERE, BUT REALLY QUICK
CONGRESSMAN?
>> I DO NOT AGREE.
MR. BARR WAS DEFINITIVE.
I MADE THIS POINT AGAIN AND
AGAIN.
HE SAID HE DIDN'T REACH A LEGAL
THRESHOLD, WEEK HAD -- HE SAID
HE FOUND NO EVIDENCE OF
CONSPIRACY.
BUT I THINK IT'S OVERLY
OPTIMISTIC FOR THOSE WHO OPPOSE
THIS PRESIDENT TO SAY THAT ONCE
AGAIN WE DIDN'T FIND WHAT WE